whenever you and i chat it's a very uh
those segments are very popular uh
because you were quite candid about your
your dating life and yeah or i'm just
going to say
a word i just made up sexploits
that's never been done before uh you
you were dating a lot before quarantine
and then suddenly
what's it like for you now it just stops
yeah you can't you can't do
anything and no guys want to even talk
because you can't there's no end
to this there's no like eventually
you're gonna hang out
i mean there's you can go on social
distance hikes
but um even that i can't even go on i
can't go see a guy i
i was recently talking to someone and i
asked my mom
if i could and it just puts them in
jeopardy so i'm i'm literally not having
sex now so that my mom doesn't die
which feels really heroic in a lot of
ways
i'm like i can't go get in the woods
right now mom because i care about your
health and it just
feels good to be able to tell her that
really you're right you're saying you're
up there with the world war ii
generation
of heroism yeah right that's exactly
what
it is because you he he can't
i don't i really i had to text a guy the
other day
um i can't go my mom and dad won't let
me
which i've never i'm about to be 36 in a
month and i just texted that i've never
had to text that before
the last time i even had to tell someone
that texting didn't exist
so that was truly the first time it's
just it's wild living at home
i um it's it's weird though because i'm
and people are like are you
horny do you want to get out there and
the truth is i'm i'm just not it's hard
people keep asking me like about um
you know if well i keep asking myself
why i'm not masturbating more and it's
because it's
weird to do when my parents aren't or
when my parents are here
you're in your you're in your parents
house i'm assuming
uh you know the walls are thin yeah
uh the dogs are small so they go take
the
dog for a walk but they're back in four
minutes it's not
enough time for me to get anything done
um they're always here
i really i sent away for my
vibrators i really i thought maybe that
was it it's just like oh i need like
some
equipment and so i had my assistant um
find them in my apartment you sent away
for them
what did you send away for them because
i well
i because i i needed them because i just
i'm not good at manual i just my hand is
is worthless to me i and i don't have a
body pillow
okay i think you misunderstood um i
wasn't
wondering why you needed to masturbate
of course right okay yes oh because i'm
a woman with needs
well please i'm i'm told i don't believe
it
oh i have an orgasm i've never
experienced that myself
oh yeah i was on i was on the road when
this all went down i didn't have
anything
okay so you didn't have access to your
equipment didn't it's all in my
apartment in new york so i had my
assistant
send it to me and i only say that so
that i can mention that i have an
assistant
but she went and she she i had to like
tell her where to
go look for them um i was like one of
them looks like an ear thermometer
one um is like a massage uh chair
just send the chair i miss rubbing up on
that thing no she sent me this huge box
and um i was like wrap it in weeds so
you can hide the smell
and uh she's just i'm gonna leave for a
second i'll be right back
all right yeah i'll i'll keep a watch
everything looks good
i'm just walking it off
get those steps in all right okay
so anyway but i haven't even used them i
like
i i told my mom saw the box before i did
and she was like this is heavy what
what's in here i was like candle sticks
like just
i don't making things up um and then
though
i don't i was just thinking of something
long and heavy
and then the power went out the other
day she's like get those candle sticks
and i'm like well they're not going to
work without power those plug
[Laughter]
they're electric candles hey mom
just shut up i don't want to but even
like
yeah masturbating and in your your house
with your parents
i didn't do it in high school i wasn't
really a sexual like teenager so i
wasn't
i wasn't doing it back then and now i'm
trying it now and it's just
it's i'm scared of making any noise i
bite down on a stick
like i'm giving birth in the wood like
i'm pocahontas
um yeah yeah you mentioned that because
i was not a sexual teenager
i became sexual uh i think during
obama's first term
that's when i really blossomed yes uh as
a sensual
uh were you really a late bloomer yes
very late bloomer yeah
yeah so was i i really didn't like boys
until
yeah i was like 28 or something i just
didn't
i didn't care and and so nothing about
living at home reminds me of like
having a sexual energy i really am
reverting back into being a teenager
again i'm listening to taylor swift in
my bedroom i'm
borrowing my parents car i'm you know
uh but pretty soon my mom's gonna be
bathing me in the sink again
it's just it's a quick descent